[Music]
what's your name
huh all right uh all right hello
everyone uh I'm Josh I'm here to talk to
you guys about
um a specific opening line so uh as you
know this is prepared like a pro and so
are we talking about uh the process for
Preparation and I'm gonna be using a
couple of key examples of the specific
opening I'm going to be looking at today
is actually the bishop G5 nighter so uh
we'll just see the so we can just take a
look at starting at the moves here
um so uh if uh you know anything about
me uh which is admittedly uh not a
guarantee uh I'm a huge fan of the
bishop G5 night Earth I've played it for
pretty much all my career my all-time
score is is somewhere in the 80s
percents range
um I used to just win every game with it
but as people get better it's a little
bit harder sometimes
so I wanted to bring to your attention a
couple of uh games and how people
including myself were able to do
preparation for them so uh first of all
so let's start off with the game so this
was a game that was played uh the
tournament after I finished my Grand
Master title I was playing an Indian I
believe he was an FM named uh bossok
sojardo so let's go with my bb7 queen E2
so this was a point where my opponent
had mostly played the move H6 which is
the main move in this position
so after H6 the line normally goes with
Bishop H4 and G6 F4 E5 and takes takes
and so so here uh I I noticed that uh in
the database that he did not really uh
seem to feel comfortable here
um he although he had played several
games and in fact this was the most
common continuation that he had played
um he had lost several games his score
with it wasn't very good I thought that
he might uh strongly consider switching
to something else so
um in preparation for the game I also
decided to check many of the other moves
for this situation
um so this tournament was was in Hungary
so in Europe as you may or may not know
tournaments are one game a day as
opposed to America where usually you
play two games in a day and therefore I
had a lot of time with which to prepare
so I also happened to check the move E6
which is the second most common move I
believe in this position
so after E6
long castles and queen C7 so here in the
past most people would just
automatically play F4 and then you would
end up with a transposition to a
different line
and there's nothing particularly wrong
with that but I discovered that the
computer is very fond of this move G3
so
the way with which you would discover uh
new moves like G3 which is uh not a
standard idea by any means so the way in
which that would work is so a computer
recommends something it's very important
to not just immediately take whatever it
says for granted
um I mean it's not a big secret nowadays
that people rely very heavily on the
computer for analysis and there's
nothing particularly wrong with that but
it's very important to notice not just
take what it says for granted because
it's still capable of saying a lot of
things that may not necessarily be
correct and it also says things that um
don't apply to every situation and the
evaluation is usually arbitrary and will
change over time but this move G3
actually makes a lot of sense it is
targeted very specifically against
Black's idea so what is black trying to
do in this position when black plays
Queen C7
so as we know black played A6 on move 5
of the game because black is playing the
Naruto which involves A6 on move 5. so
the idea for black yes very good chess
lover in chat the idea for black is to
play B5 so the idea behind G3 is to
significantly complicate the idea of
black playing B5 so for example if black
were to play B5 in this position after
Bishop G2
uh in the case of a move like uh Bishop
B7 after F4 the threat of E5 here is
actually incredibly strong
um so in the case of something Bishop E7
which would be the most natural move so
so far black has only played the most
natural moves uh black has developed a
piece on every single turn and in this
position uh black is already losing
after the move E5 because after takes
takes black is ending up in a situation
where uh Bishop takes G2 Queen takes G2
results in uh multiple pieces being
under attack in this position and so uh
black would be forced to play 95 which
is not an ideal situation and the King
on E7 is under uh a winning attack
yeah so black would have to do something
different and it turns out that the
Tactical waves were in which black can
resolve this problem with B4 uh these
are generally not going to work out B4
is pretty much always going to be met by
Knight D5 in this setting and uh yeah
white is going to be winning here as
well so that's when I thought that this
idea was uh worth investigating with G3
and so instead my opponent played Bishop
E7 and moved earlier
and so here what I had done in my
analysis in the in the morning or the
night before I don't quite remember but
um I remember I was looking at Bishop G2
and uh here if black plays B5 then we
would just simply transpose to uh this
position
after black plays Bishop E7 which is the
most likely so Bishop E7
so unfortunately during the game I
didn't remember all this because uh I
attracted yeah so I definitely had
checked this the night before and during
the morning I Was preparing something
else so unfortunately I did play F4
first but the idea remains very similar
so in the case of Bishop G2 I believe
what I was concerned about was black
going for some idea with Knight B6 to
try to take over the C4 Square which is
newly weakened but this just goes to
show how your preparation is going to
differ significantly from whatever you
end up calculating in the game because
people think differently from how they
do in the preparation
so unfortunately I did play F4 first
because my logic was okay after B5 I
would just Bishop G2 but unfortunately
what I'd failed to realize was that
Bishop G2 actually prevents B5 entirely
um because uh in this case white would
simply play E5 and the rook and knights
would not be both defensible at the same
time
so instead I just opted for F4 and after
B5 Bishop G2 B4 yes unfortunately
because black does have the bishop on E7
already Knight D5 is not particularly
effective in this position
um it's and so I did go for E5
and a couple of moves later uh black
ended up in the situation where uh
if black were to take on G5 black would
have excellent compensation for the uh
exchange here but instead black ended up
taking on A8 and ended up with a bad
position but either way the point here
is regarding how Black's surprise at the
new move ended up in a situation where
black was not able to find all the
optimal moves even though I had already
messed up so
yeah I just wanted to go over the
thought process behind this move G3 and
how uh although I actually currently
believe it to be the best possible move
in the position and even though it looks
very strange it's really important that
when you ever you see a computer idea
you want to be looking at the idea
behind the move and whether it makes
sense and whether it's consistent with
how you are playing
so
um I also want to bring to mind what I
had in mind for H6
so in this position so in this position
historically most people have just
automatically played long castles based
on the idea that e takes D4 is not going
to be possible thanks to E5
and uh yeah this is completely winning
for white this has been uh pretty well
documented for a while
but uh the problem was I never really
understood why people were so adamant on
Long castling first since after Queen C7
uh well now he takes D4 as possible so
white plays Knight B3 anyway
so this move Knight B3 on move 11 first
was actually something that I thought of
before the computer if I'm remembering
correctly so the idea is that so in this
position after long cast was Queen 7
Knight B3 B5 uh yeah White's King is
committed to the queen side and
therefore the there is some pressure
that is available for black here the
main line in the past starts with Knight
D5 and eventually there's supposed to be
some long Perpetual check here following
some strange lines
but either way so this is not something
that I advise white to play for so in a
recent game I had against a grand master
Al uh actually I believe he's an
international Master but over 2500 feet
uh Al Greenberg so I decided to bring
out the move Knight B3 which is actually
something I had prepared initially for
the previous game against the sock and
um
and ended up being useful here
so Knight B3
and then
so in this position black has a couple
of moves so the really interesting
portion of the move Knight B3 is that
white actually has a lot of options here
in keeping the King on E1 so for example
if black wishes to place the queen on C7
just like what would happen against long
castling so in this position of course
if white were and were to end up on cast
link then black would simply play V5 and
we would have a transposition to the
previous situation
but by starting with queen of three
um now black has a interesting choice
where uh it's very natural for black to
protect the Knight on F6 with either of
the bishop moves Bishop E7 or Bishop G7
so generally speaking in this Pawn
structure the black Bishop does not
particularly want to go to G7 because it
is not doing much uh as it is blocked by
the own Pawn on E5 so in this position
the most natural move for black appears
like bishop and seven
but the problem for black here is that
uh they're
is a specific tactic for white that is
available here so uh in this position
after White Castles long white actually
has a very dangerous threat here so in
this position if black were to play
something like uh B5 um does anyone know
what white might be able to do here
yes very good Omar we have Rook takes D7
and because of the configuration the
black pieces the nylon F6 is loose so
obviously Bishop takes D7 we run into
Bishop takes F6 and if black were to
take with Knight on D7 then the
unfortunate positioning of that E7
Bishop means that White's simply going
to be able to take it and follow up with
Knight D5 so in this position after
after long castles black would have to
resort to something like G5 which is
clearly not a position that ideal by any
means and white is much better in this
position
so after Queen F3 in the case of Bishop
G7 then in this case white is actually
not going to Castle long because of the
fear of the B5 move so uh my game with
Greenberg continued with A4 and castles
A5 and I ended up with the great
position here which unfortunately I
later blundered and lost in time trouble
but I had a very pleasant position the
entire game
so I just wanted to explain the thought
process behind the uh move of Knight B3
here
okay
um so there are a couple of other games
that I want to talk about and these will
probably be a little bit more extensive
since they're not my own games so I
intend on going through the games in
more detail
so uh so we start with the same sequence
Bishop G5 and in this case we're looking
at the move E6
so after E6 F4 so there are two lines
for black that have been the major uh
defensive bastions uh in the recent
history so one of them uh well okay so I
should start by giving a little bit of a
historical overview here so uh Queen B6
introduces the infamous poison Pawn
variation which is not a particularly
um
favored by uh most players there's
nothing particularly wrong with it
um but it's just a very complicated
position and therefore a lot of players
don't feel comfortable with it so
a lot of people at Players nowadays are
playing this line Knight being seven
which is considered to be pretty solid
for black so I remember here I was doing
some analysis with my colleague so I had
a friend here who I was helping with
this line and so after Queen F3 Queen C7
we reach the main position of the E6
Knight D7 Knight Earth this is a super
common line
um in this position there are a lot of
different options for white so one thing
I was we were looking at was with long
castling so this is the old line with
long castles B5 and then Bishop D3
and so black normally plays Bishop B7
and in this position black has several
options
so the idea for for uh White here is
that uh with the bishop on E7 white is
normally looking for the plan with G4
and G5 but because the e-file is vacant
it is usually considered to be stronger
for white to proceed with the rookie E1
plan preparing Knight D5
so in this position black has several
options but uh for the most part the
lines are considered to be pretty dead
um they usually will end up in some long
Perpetual check especially after 95 so
95 is one line after green takes D4
takes takes yeah this is considered to
be uh roughly equal position where black
has three pieces versus the queen it
looks very abstract but this has
actually been known for many years long
before the computer age
um
and there are other lines as well the
line of Bishop E7 in particular is uh is
quite popular these days and yeah
there's some extremely extensive Theory
here I believe the only strong white
player that still continues to go into
this line is that P show and uh or I'm
actually not sure how to pronounce his
name but I'll pretend that I do and I'll
say it's P show and I believe he
actually won some game against Robson I
think but uh yeah the line in particular
I don't regard as very promising so my
friend and I were looking for ways to uh
avoid the
drawish line here with nine long castles
so one way I was investigating which I
believe has been played by Nakamura in
the past as it was with G4 and B5 Bishop
takes F6 so for black here uh the most
natural move Knight takes F6 has some
issues so in the case of G5 97 long
castles the problem for black is that
because the Knight is forced off of F6
there is no time to include both Bishop
B7 and B4 simultaneously so in the case
of B4 white simply continues with Knight
D5 and unleashes a very powerful attack
unfortunately for white uh the inclusion
of the move G4 is not positionally
desirable in the case of the Richter
Rouser Pawn structure so after G takes
F6 uh this position is not considered to
be very promising for white
so in the course of looking for other
options my friend and I realized
something so we ran into this line with
uh seven Bishop E7 and after Queen C7
Knight D7 the main move here is G4 but a
main alternative to this move is with F5
so my friend and I were thinking about
how after F5 Black's best move here is
95 and so then we were thinking about
how okay well so why is this so
different then what if in this position
with the black Bishop on f8 then F5 was
played
so after F5 here uh Knight E5 is
slightly less desirable because the
bishop is going to capture on F6 and
double the pawns so uh without the
bishop on E7 95 is a little bit weaker
than it was before so after F5 uh my
friend who I will
okay
give the friend reveal again I'm not
sure what happened it was like a glitch
or something
okay okay great great
um yes so uh okay perhaps uh perhaps
YouTube did not want me to uh reveal the
name of my friend so uh he is he is in
software so uh you never know
um anyway so so so yes uh after Queen
Seven which I Was preparing for my
friend uh International Master Edward
song so I was helping him with the study
of this line uh again for his game
against Grandmaster Robbie kavlish
Philly so after Queen C7 so essentially
we were thinking about playing the move
at five here
uh to parallel the line where Black's
Bishop is already on E7 but trying to
reach a uh if not improved a slightly
different version of that line where the
move Knight E5 is no longer as feasible
because the Knight on F6 is not
supported by a bishop and therefore
enables the doubling of the pawns here
so
in the case of E5 which is the other
natural way for black to react to the
the right on E6 we were analyzing Knight
B3 and so in this position black should
play B5 to develop the light Square
Bishop quickly and in this position uh
White is not particularly better in this
position but one thing you'll realize is
that as the black player becomes better
prepared with the white pieces at the
end of the day everything is going to be
more or less allowing black to equalize
at the end of the day there's not really
anything you can do about it chess is a
drop so the important thing is you want
to play something that gives you some
chances to play the game since as with
white you will always be or more or less
always be in a situation where you want
to be preparing for a win and um
so you want to play something where the
game is not completely dead and you want
to be playing something that enables
some outplay potential or where your
opponent may not necessarily feel
comfortable and so that's the goal that
white is trying to achieve here
so in this position after D5 uh White
starts with Bishop takes F6 Knight takes
F6 and long castles so it looks
incredibly strange for the
for so so it definitely looks incredibly
strange for white to go the dark Square
Bishop but the thing to realize here is
that the pawn structure that's going to
be arising from this opening is going to
include the eventual move Knight D5 and
after Knight takes D5 he takes D5 we
will end up with a certain Pawn
structure so let's keep following the
game so we addition E7 uh the bishop
generally does not belong on B7 in this
position because after G4
so if black now wants to force Knight to
D5
definitely white black does not want to
be capturing this Knight on D5 with the
bishop because the nylon F6 is going to
be a target for White's kingside
expansion and in the case of the Knight
capturing on D5 the bishop is not doing
anything in particular on B7 this D5
Pawn is never going to be under threat
and meanwhile and white is probably
going to end up parking the F1 Bishop on
e4 and advancing the king side pawns so
the position is very closed and
definitely black is not like super duper
worse or anything like that but it's
definitely very difficult for black to
find a secure plant
so Cutlass really continues with Bishop
East Evan in their game and so after
King V1 which is a natural prophylactic
move now black is looking for Bishop B7
and Knight D5 takes takes
so in this position
after Queen B6 G4 we see that white has
obtained a position where despite
lacking a serious advantage on account
of the opposite colored Bishops and the
super closed position here in particular
the one of the main problems White's
position is that the Knight on B3 is
very poorly placed
white would much rather have gone this
way if it were feasible in the original
position but unfortunately it was not so
uh definitely black is not like in a
super terrible position or anything like
that but it's very difficult for black
to find the plan whereas what a White's
plan is very obvious so for practical
games uh definitely seems like uh like
uh the position is easier for white to
play and that's really all that matters
in the long run Omar asks isn't black
position insecure in that case because
his King side is attacked and queen side
is exposed uh yes so what blacks
generally is safe is positioned for the
king here would actually be in the
center on E8 or f8
um or on the queen side since it's quite
difficult for white to open the queen
side but yes you're absolutely correct
that that the black king definitely
faces some difficulties here so in the
game we can see that very quickly uh
black ended up in a tough situation so
after Bond castling my friend Edward is
very strong player managed to find a
brilliant move here F6 so the idea here
is that after Bishop takes F6 G5 the
dark Square Bishop is not going to be
able to move anywhere where and after H
takes G5 H takes G5
Bishop takes G5 is not possible due to
the fork on G4
and and a retreat of the bishop would
drop the F7 Pawn with a serious issue
for black
so kevlish really ended up taking with
the g-pawn but it's very clear here that
black has a really terrible position so
after Bishop F5 King B8 94.
um now we can see that all the whites
pieces are in their optimal positions
and that dark Square Bishop for black is
very poor so after King A7 Edward
unlocks it likes to trade the knights
and continue to improve the pieces
starting with Rook D3 very nice move so
uh yeah big problem for black is that
there's just no counter play available
but all there's there's no real way to
improve the dark Square Bishop which is
just not possible to be activated
and then so College Philly plays B4 to
prevent the potential invasion of C6
through Rook C3
but after Rook C1 so again another big
problem for black here is that the C
file cannot be challenged due to this
dominating light Square Bishop so after
Rook B8 Rook B3 uh White was able to
force the C file open but unfortunately
uh my friend was too comfortable with
the draw here and elected to allow the
exchange of Rooks and from there on
black was able to save the position by
using a bishop to cover C7 and
relatively soon after the game ended in
a draw
however if a white had elected to not do
that and probably start by taking the
b-pawn taking with the B Rook then most
likely black would have ended up losing
the game since the dark screwed Bishop
is in a very poor position and it's very
difficult for black to activate the
pieces
so uh just another Showcase of how uh
White more or less could have won this
game out of the opening if uh things had
gone a little bit better and so yeah the
preparation there played a key part in
obtaining a great position where even if
he did not end up winning the game uh my
friend definitely ended up in a game
where against a stronger player than him
a GM who has more than 100 points higher
rated than him he reached a position
very quickly where there's absolutely
zero risk of losing
okay
I think Gary covers this yeah I think
Gary uh starts with a different mood
board I believe Gary starts with Bishop
E7 against which it is different so uh
here F5 and then E5 is I believe covered
in the Geary course
um and yes Knight Earth is part of
facility so uh funnily enough uh it's
kind of funny that you mentioned the
Geary course because the last example I
wish to bring up here is also related to
uh the Gary course and in fact much
closely much more closely so
so uh the last game we're going to look
at today and uh hopefully this is going
to be the longest of the games for sure
um is played by another friend of mine
but this one I did not help him prepare
so the game we're going to be looking at
right now is with between Andrew Hong
playing white and David Brodsky playing
Black both players strong Grand Masters
this would have been played in the US
junior Championship I believe of last
summer so uh yeah very tense game two
players roughly the same rating around
2500 so we see Bishop E7 Queen F3 Queen
C7 on Castle is Knight bd7 so
historically uh most people did not
really play this line with black anymore
after G4
so uh the most popular move in the past
would have been V5 but after Bishop
takes F6 Knight takes F6 G5 Knight D7
and F5 uh most people with black ended
up not liking this position uh because
of various reasons but essentially the
white attack on the king side is very
strong and therefore was not considered
to be desirable for most players
so uh Gary's idea here in his course so
um it was very surprising to me at least
when Gary ended up recommending this
line because uh it's just not a very
popular anymore and most people had
thought it was just good for white but
Gary was suggesting line with H6 which
has been well known in the past so in
this position uh funnily enough I
actually did lose a terrible game back
in 2012 or so where I made the
positional mistake of Bishop H4
and in this position uh yeah black has a
really excellent move here to uh punish
White's uh poor uh choice in the last
few moves
yes and chess lover is correct with G5
so after F takes g595
um it's a very typical idea in the
bishop G5 naidorf but particularly here
white is has a serious problem because
the move G4 is something that white
really wishes to take back and after
losing the g-pawn white is going to be
in a worse position
so after H6 uh White predominantly takes
an F6 and uh so in this line black does
not want to recapture with the Knight
this time since after uh H4 the move G5
is going to be very uncomfortable for
black
so black usually recaptures the bishop
I just had a game go Queen H3 yeah Queen
H3 is interesting but after Bishop takes
F6 Bishop takes F6 so now uh
H4 and in this position uh the main move
in the past was Queen B6 so
of course black doesn't want to allow G5
for free and
the opening of the king side again is
not something black wants to deal with
for example if black were to play like
this and then just simply Retreat then
after G6 uh the king side is just
completely falling apart here that H6
move you can see uh why you're advised
not to push pawns on the same side in
which you are being attacked so by
losing control of the G6 Square the F7
and E6 squares are going to become under
serious pressure
so historically the main move was Queen
V6 but after Knight de2 which I believe
to be superior than the more common
Knight V3 after Knight D2 black is not
going to be able to stop G5 for very
long and therefore black has going to be
having some trouble
um for the record uh after Knight B3 I
believe the best move for black is
actually Queens of seven and then white
returns with Knight D4 so that should
give some context as to what black is
really hoping for when this line appears
on the board
so Gary's idea instead involves the move
Knight B6
so this move is a good move
um there's nothing in particular that's
that's very wrong with it
um but I'm not personally a huge fan of
this line for black because uh so a
couple of things so first of all I don't
know about you but for me personally I
play the nardorf I'm going to be in a
situation where I really want to be
playing for a win and many of the major
lines here are going to be ending in
Fairly drawish positions so for example
uh so Knight B6 of course black is
inviting the moon G5 this is not a big
secret that white wants to play G5 I
would not play H4 if G5 was not the
purpose
so after G5 one of the main lines goes
like Bishop takes D4 Rook takes D4 and
uh
Queen C5 and Rook D2 so uh and black is
going to try to equalize by virtue of
the idea Knight A4 and trading some
pieces so this is one of the main lines
and it ends up being okay for black yeah
so
yeah this is one of the main lines and
it ends up being pretty even for black
uh The Limited material makes it so that
White's attack is not going to be very
successful and that is indeed the major
purpose of this line for black
so uh so so yeah I think that this line
is is fine for black technically like uh
black is equalizing but I believe that
there are a lot of dangerous tries
available to White and I think that the
best case scenario for black is not
really in line with what most Sicilian
players are trying to achieve anyway so
uh so yeah just not the personal uh not
a personal favorite of mine but in any
case uh wine is very solid and it
remains that white needs to find
something to do against it
so in the case of Queen C5 so so far
we've actually done exactly what has
happened between Grand Masters Andrew
Hong and David Brodsky uh in the game
that I was mentioning before
and in this position so yes uh believe
it or not all three of the white Rook
retreats to D3 D2 and D1 are valuable
as we mentioned before Rook D2 is the
main one
but in this position uh Andrew hung
decided to go for the move Queen F2
now I don't know about you but I thought
the move Queen F2 looks extremely silly
um I think when I first saw this game I
found it uh
a little bit hard to believe
um
it definitely seems as if the uh pinned
down the A7 to G1 diagonal is not
optimal for white it's definitely not
something you want to be subjecting
yourself to if you don't have a good
reason
additionally Queen F2 is also weird
because after H takes G5 it seems like
the most positionally desirable
recapture for what would be H takes G5
so for example
um
after Queen C5 or rather if black took
on G5 in this position white would take
this way because the open H file is very
beneficial to White for example after
takes takes the threat of Queen h8 is
already extremely serious and also
because uh White simply wants to keep
the pawn structure intact control that
E5 square and look to push for G6 or F5
or something like this
so queen queen F2 looks a little bit
bizarre because after H takes G5 white
is not going to be able to play H takes
G5 due to this pin down the H file
so uh Queen F2 yeah again another very a
very bizarre move
um it also looks like another thing that
black would like to play as E5 so after
F takes E5 if D takes E5 were to happen
and white had to play Rook D2 and black
is going to be very happy in its
position just winning an extra Pawn for
nothing
but unfortunately for black after G
takes E5 so the first major idea of
Queen F2 is that E5 is not possible
because of the discovered check with
rook d8 and the Queen on C5 will drop
off
so if black were to play E5 black would
have to end up taking with a queen but
this is very much a positionally
undesirable and if black wants to
survive he'll have to try to evacuate
the king from the center with Bishop D7
but after Rook B4 uh black is going to
be dropping the B Pawn and the position
is completely lost for Block
so E5 is not a viable move in this
position so that is the first idea of
Queen F2
so after Queen F2 uh and if so another
idea of Queen F2 is that if black were
to continue with Bishop D7 just like
black would play against Rook D2
remember Rook D2 black wants to play
Bishop D7
and continue with Knight A4 and try to
exchange the pieces so after Queen F2 if
black were to continue in the same way
with Bishop D7 then after Pawn takes H6
Rook takes H6 Queen D2 We realize that
what black has done actually doesn't
really make that much sense because uh
the room Knight A4 is not possible in
this position because white has never
actually retreated or retreated The Rook
from D4 and also black has a lot of
problems with the D6 Pawn so for example
in the case of long castling white would
probably start with B4 but then follow
up with the capture on D6
and for the most part uh White is going
to be up upon here there are several
sample lines I have available the move
B4 is important to secure the queen on
D4 and Bishop C6 can actually be met by
B5 which is very strong
so these are the two uh so these are two
of the main ideas of Queen F2 so as you
can see it's a very smart move to which
has many ideas behind it
so after Queen F2 so of course the major
question that remains to be answered for
white is the move H takes G5 because as
we mentioned before White's normal
positionally desirable response of H
takes G5 is not going to be available in
this game
so after H takes G5 so uh chest lever is
completely right if white were to play F
takes G5 then simply E5 Rook D2 takes
takes and after Bishop E6 black is an
incredibly harmonious position here and
we'll probably continue with King E7
um and in the meantime White's light
screw the ship is going to be restricted
by that E4 pawn and Black's pieces all
coordinate very well white is a bad Pawn
structure if anything black should be
the one who holds the advantage in this
position
so H takes G5 is exactly what David
Brodsky played in the game My my
impression is that Brodsky is most
likely uh not uh most likely brosky was
not familiar with this line which makes
sense since Queen F2 was a complete
novelty at the time
and it is also not suggested by the
computer as the first choice and that's
another really important value of modern
Novelties as we stated before one of the
most important parts of preparation
nowadays is that since everything is
going to be equal as is going to be
equal in the long run since chess is a
drop it doesn't really matter if the
engine rates it as highly as possible
but um
it doesn't really matter if the engine
rates are as highly as possible what
matters a lot more is how it fares in
human play so after H takes G5 which is
the most obvious move of course F takes
G5 was not the idea the idea of the move
was to follow up with E5
so after E5 now this looks incredibly
bizarre uh I don't know about you but so
the first point of the move is that
again D takes E5 simply loses to Rook d8
right so D takes E5 would simply lose to
rook d8 and picking up the queen again
and in the case of D5 now white should
be able to uh make to make use of the
exposed King side since the center is
now closed and indeed there is actually
a trick immediately with the move 94. so
after 94 uh
D takes E4 is not possible again on
account of Rook d8 so therefore black
will be forced to invite the Knight into
D6 which would leave white with a
winning attack
so this is the first idea of this move
E5 so as you can see every move that
this guy is playing has multiple ideas
and that's what happens when you are a
strong Grand Master
so after E5 black is already at a
serious uh what likes already having a
serious issue because the Knight E4 is
threatened with the double attack on the
queen and the D6 pawn and if blackward
allow 94 and Knight takes D6 then
probably black would have to resign very
soon for example uh Rook takes H4 Rook
takes h4g takes H4 and 94.
would result in a winning attack for
white after say queen C6 or whatever
Knight takes D6 uh I don't know where to
put the king maybe d8 or something but
this is very obviously not what black is
wanting to be doing
so after E5
um so another uh so Brodsky continues to
play the best moves with G takes F4 so G
takes F4 is pretty much a necessary move
in this position so the idea is that
after Knight E4 black is now able to
play Queen takes E5 and meet Knight
takes D6 shot with King E7 so now
because black is up so many pawns the
white attack is no longer winning
believe it or not white actually has a
lot of funny ways to make draws like for
example uh starting with Knight takes F7
is possible and this position uh the
black king is so exposed that the extra
Knight is not particularly good enough
to help black to win and if we just
follow some sample moves we can see uh
that how eventually the game should end
in draw and the same applies for the
moon Rook takes that four the other
night sacrifice and yeah eventually the
game should be ending in a draw somehow
so instead
um
Brodsky sorry Hong rather sees that he
doesn't want to be uh forcing black to
play good moves so after G takes off
four simply continues with Bishop D3
and this is something that you would
have to prepare with the computer in the
movie Bishop D3 is definitely not
findable in a serious game so after
Bishop D3 or rather I should say that
it's not that it's not findable but you
would never go into this line if you had
not reached this point already since all
black has really done so far as black
has just taken multiple pawns and
there's nothing particularly wrong with
that obviously like if you can take
pawns you should take pawns but when you
whenever you're preparing A variation
you always need to check what happens if
your opponent takes your pawns right so
I have to Bishop D3 so black is out of
Crossroads here so once again D takes E5
is losing to Rook d8 as we established
before right
so uh D takes E5 does not work uh Queen
takes E5 is the other natural move to
take the third Pawn
um and so in this position black is up
three pawns which is amazing but what's
much less amazing is that after Rook E1
so again Queen C5 is not possible
because of 94 followed by Knight takes
D6 with a winning attack for white as
this time white will not see the need to
give up a knight
so after a queen H5 Rook takes F4 so
black is up two pawns but the attack is
completely decisive there's no way for
black to hold all the threats the B6
Knight is hanging to start with and if
black choose to saber something like 97
and white can proceed with 94 and all
the various points in Black's position
are very soon going to fall apart so
cautionary tale as to make sure that if
you play Sicilian you are defending all
of your pieces and you really know your
stuff
the only reason that it's possible by
the way for Hong to have prepared this
far is because brosky is a relatively
inflexible player who plays the night
Earth in pretty much all of his games
with black against E4 so uh also you
could view the game as a cautionary tale
that if you do this which is perfectly
possible has its advantages and
disadvantages you really need to make
sure that you have all your bases
covered and another big problem with it
is that while people often say this
about the top Grandmaster maximum vashio
de grav
that if you play the same thing every
game there are going to be games that
you lose and you can't do anything about
it because your opponent will simply
prepare further than you and you will
not be able to expect this ever since
it's just how trust works
but that's not a problem for the
majority of the club players definitely
um so uh yeah please don't worry about
it if anything I recommend to most
if anything I recommend to most amateur
players who just continue playing the
same thing as much as possible as long
as they enjoy it because the most
important thing is to enjoy what you
play so that you can stick with it and
therefore learn it better
so after Bishop D3
um
yeah so uh so in this position white is
actually threatening uh 94 in Earnest so
after Bishop D7 we can see what happens
if there is no particular threat after
94 Queen takes E5 96 King E7 and Rook E1
uh this is another position where
White's attack is completely decisive so
uh in order for black to prevent the
threat of Knight E4 the only way for
black to do so is D5
so the reason why this line is so potent
for white as a one-off surprise weapon
is because D5 is very poor on the
previous move but in this position it
turns out to be the only move that
avoids immediate loss so
uh in this case after 94 the attack is
not as strong so in the case of 94 black
takes an E4 and because of a specific
detail black is avoiding loss in this
position with the in-between move Knight
D7 and the bishop and queen are both
under attack if white tries to insert
his own in-between move with Queen A5
black has a third in-between move with
B6 and on the next move black is going
to be able to capture the bishop on D3
so as you can see this is why this is so
hard to find over the board because most
likely what broadski was thinking about
was that D5 okay so D5 in this position
is positionally desirable to cover that
E4 square but after D5
uh 94. uh most likely he quickly
dismissed this as losing because after
takes Rook takes King takes Queen C5 the
United B6 would be hanging with check
and should allow white time to save the
bishop and most likely he didn't look
any further for Knight D7 so in order to
play D5 over the board you would have to
see that this is available and we can
see that another part of Hong's genius
for this game was that this position is
not even bad for white after Rook G1 G6
and 92 black actually still needs to
play fairly precisely in order to
equalize from this position
um
and in this position
um black needs to find the move Knight
D7
and after Rook G5
um in this position White's activity is
pretty much only sufficient to equalize
with the pawn down so white is
compensation but probably nothing more
than that and the game should end in
some sort of Perpetual check
so essentially what Hong has done here
is that he has risked very little
because he knows the line and will make
a draw if uh if it happens to not be
successful if black happens Define all
the perfect moves over the board and if
black is not successful and plays a move
like F5 which is what happened in the
game then he will win immediately so F5
looks very natural to also prevent
Knight E4 and in this case after he
takes F6
uh the natural move for black is E5 so
at first it looks like The Rook is lost
on D4 to the pin and that is in fact
completely correct The Rook on D4 is not
going to be a salvageable away from this
pin uh Rook takes F4 is not sufficient
because after e takes F4 The Black Queen
on C5 is protected
but in the greatest Twist of Misfortune
for Brodsky after F takes G7 Rook G8
Bishop G6 check so for example King d8
here or any king move to the D file
would lose immediately to Rook ticks D6
Queen takes D6 and Rook D1 picking up
the queen on D6
so King E7 is absolutely forced and then
white continues with a brilliant move
here so white would love to bring in the
queen to uh check that King on E7 and
the only way to do so is also happens to
be incredibly beautiful and completely
winning
so again white does not want to play
Rook D2 or something because white would
succeed in Saving the queen but would
lose the G7 pawn and in this position
black should be winning with the extra
material
so again this is impossible for black to
determine over the board that this is
losing so another case where we can see
how brilliant the choice of preparation
was
the correct move for white in this
position which is the best move and I
believe confers an advantage in the plus
seven to plus eight territory is H5 and
after Queen takes D4 Queen H4 King D7 uh
Queen G1 suggested by a ROM but the
reason that this is so strong is because
in this position
um white saves the G7 Pawn with the move
H6
and after H6 black is not able to
prevent H7 and is completely lost so for
example after a king C7 H7
um yeah it's kind of sad but after
Bishop D7 white simply promotes the
queen and white is going to be up two
queens
so in the game black played King C6
um
so in this position if H7 you can at
least take on G7 and take on G6 and
maybe you can survive here given that uh
you have a bishop and a rook and several
pawns and there's no immediate Checkmate
so far
in this position there are several ways
to win
um the one that the computer favors the
most is Rook D1 allowing the exchange of
Queens
with Queen H3 or the attempt to exchange
Queens rather but after Queen E7 black
is going to be losing because the King
on C6 is far too vulnerable and queen E6
Bishop E4 is winning but my guess is
that probably hung was already out of
prep because it is move 24 after all and
um and black has played a losing move
several moves ago so most likely if I
was hung what I would have done is
determined exactly how black is losing
and probably reached this position with
H6 in my notes before the game and then
afterward would have a
determined that just tried to play over
the board
so Hong played Bishop E4
and after King C7 I decided to just
continue with Queen F6 to support that
G7 pawn and threaten H7 on the next boot
so we had Bishop D7
and it is a little bit messy because
black is up a rook but unfortunately at
the end of the day the black books are
just not useful in comparison to the
white passed Pawns
so after Rook D1
Queen E3 King B1 yeah unfortunately
white has no particular need to look for
any knockout blows or anything like this
because black is simply positionally
lost up an entire rook and oh actually
black is not actually up any pawns which
I just realized but up an entire Rook
Black's not able to save the position
so in an effort to escape from Queen
takes D6 Brodsky decides to go for a
king V8 in order to hide that King on A7
unfortunately
the past pawns on the king side are so
strong that not only does white pick up
one Rook white picks up two Rooks
so the game finished with Rook C3 Pawn
takes C3 Queen takes E4 Queen ff8
Knight C8 and after Queen G1 check uh
Brodsky finally resigned because he is
down two queens well okay sorry I
shouldn't say that black is down a queen
uh for pretty much nothing and the black
king continues to suffer difficulties
so yeah I would really want to bring up
this game because I thought the
preparation that had been done here was
uh truly incredible it's definitely of a
very rare level uh usually you don't see
this sort of thing up and outside of the
top GM level games
um yeah Queen F2 very smart and
yeah so this is again this is actually a
problem with learning your openings from
books or courses or things like this
where if your opponent knows what's what
the contents of that course are then
they can look for a tries that are not
covered and the problem with chess in
the uh modern day is that it is
impossible to cover everything
so as we said before Queen F2 is not
even a move that is rated highly by the
engine
for the most part Rook D2 my stockfish
at least rates book D2 in the 0.3 to 0.5
area which is basically nothing but
Queen F2 is around point zero zero or
something like this so yeah it just goes
to show how important it is to make sure
that you are ready for everything
so
uh
all right so I think that's
so I think that's all there is to say
for this game yeah just really clever
here uh remember how uh with D5 Knight
E4 in this position is winning but in
this position D5 is the only move so
yeah just just show how
strong that was there
um
I think that's all I had prepared
actually
um I'm a little bit short is that fine
or yeah oh okay all right yeah so uh all
right so so yeah that's all I have today
I hope that was uh instructional for
everybody there
um
yeah nidorf is a good opening but you do
have to be very careful when you play it
so uh yeah I just wanted to show some
cases of excellent preparation uh
particularly this Hong game I think you
guys can learn a lot from it not really
because of the specific moves or
anything but the thought process and how
he got there so yes thank you so much
everybody
foreign
[Music]